d'accord un virus qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences sur les patients qui en ont
été atteints plus important que prévu
d'ailleurs ses conséquences en france
plus de cent mille personnes ont été
hospitalisées après avoir contracté la
coved 19 pour certains d'entre les
conséquences se font sentir plusieurs
mois après la guérison notamment sur les
poumons et ça se traduit par des
troubles respiratoires chroniques et
irréversible mais pour l'instant il ya
peu de données chiffrées sur l'ampleur
du phénomène pour en parler justement va
rejoindre jean philippe masson médecin
radiologue libéral à carcassonne et les
présidents également de la fédération
des médecins radiologues
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors en tant qu
aux radiologues ce que vous avez
constaté des lésions pulmonaires graves
sur les patients qui ont été atteints à
de lakovic 19
alors oui bord dont des phases aiguës
bien entendu il y a eu beaucoup d'
images typiques du coc vie de 19 ans
convoyaient et d'ailleurs il faut dire
que la spécificité du scanner thoracique
était presque meilleur que les fameux
tests pcr puisque l'on savait et on
s'est toujours qu'il ya un certain
nombre de faux négatifs dans les tests
pcr souvent d'ailleurs lié à la
réalisation de ces fameux tests
le scanner thoracique est tellement
flagrant tellement typique que
immédiatement il ya un certain nombre de
sociétés de jeux new start up qui ont
lancé des outils d'intelligence
artificielle d'ailleurs pour aider des
radiologues
ils les ont mis à disposition
gratuitement et c'est les images du vide
sont tellement typique que
rétrospectivement on a trouvé des
scanner thoracique des en novembre le
responsable scientifique de ce qu'est
decaux vide donc on peut c'est à vous le
chef de service de l'hôpital de colmar
d'ailleurs qui a fait cette étude
rétrospective et ce qui montre bien que
ce virus en fait il était en france
depuis novembre sur les lésions
pulmonaires graves
les stigmates justement de du
coronavirus qu'est ce que vous avez pu
constater à ce niveau 1
après la guerre alors alors après la
guérison il reste des images qui la
plupart du temps sont des images qui
font penser qu'il y à une fibrose
pulmonaire qui apparaît c'est l'image la
plus courante et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
va entraîner ses difficultés
respiratoires pour les patients alors
les images que c'est qu'elle rcd
cicatrices en réalité ne sont pas là
pour le coup spécifique du coc vide mais
la plupart du temps ce sont des images
de fibrose donc de deux cicatrices
c'est vrai que les infections
pulmonaires elles peuvent avoir des
conséquences vous allez nous d'ailleurs
nous nous le dira confirmez est ce que
c'est réellement différent de ce que
vous avez pu observer concernant le
coronavirus dans la phase aiguë oui
c'était complètement différent
c'était des images qui étaient
bilatérales d'ailleurs qui donc qui
touchait les deux poumons
systématiquement avec un certain nombre
d'aspects il y avait cinq aspects assez
typique qui avait été décrit et qu'on a
retrouvés à chaque fois donc là oui
c'est quelque chose qui est très
spécifique dans la phase aiguë dans la
phase de cicatrices la phase où on est
maintenant pour les gens qui ont été
atteints et qui ont nom
l'irie là ce sont des images qui sont
beaucoup moins spécifiques et la plupart
du temps et qui sont des images de
cicatrisation encore une fois comme on
voit après je dirais pratiquement
n'importe quel n'importe quel nouveau
bâti la société de pneumologie de langue
française craint l'apparition d'une
nouvelle maladie face à l'ampleur de la
tante pulmonaire on en parle à on en
parlait à l'instant sur les patients est
ce que vous vous êtes du même avis ah
oui je pense qu'il va y avoir des
séquelles et des ces quelques longueurs
peut être arriverons de pas sont assis
dieuze c'est à dire qu'ils auront ce
n'est qu' un certain nombre de personnes
qui ont été atteintes par cette épidémie
par le grand navire us mais qui nous
rend pas eu de candidat de pathologies
suffisamment importante de troubles
suffisamment important pour être
hospitalisés ou pour même passé un
scanner thoracique
ces gens là ils ont eu une espèce de
grippe une espèce de malaise général et
il est vraisemblable que ils pourront
avoir eu aussi des séquelles qu'on
découvrira ultérieurement à l'occasion
d'un scanner thoracique parce que ce
qu'il faut absolument que vos auditeurs
ou téléspectateurs sache c'est que le
meilleur examen pour le diagnostic du
coran d'un virus et le diagnostic de la
maladie pulmonaire due coronavirus verna
cas c'est le scanner thoracique et ce
scanner thoracique le problème en france
c'est qu'on n'a pas assez de scanner on
est dans les pays d'europe en nombre de
scanners par million d'habitants et ça
c'est un véritable problème le dans la
chronique qu'il était juste avant moi
le commentateur disait très bien que les
médecins
était un peu inquiet sur la prise en
charge nous sommes inquiets parce que
nous ne savons pas si nous aurons assez
de scanners pour pouvoir passer les
scanner thoracique pression donc c'était
un nouvel appel que vous lancez après
celui déjà vous aviez lancé le 12 mars
dernier vous avez lancé un appel au
ministre de la santé pour demander
davantage de masques d'ailleurs à ce
niveau est ce que vous êtes satisfait
aujourd'hui et puis votre avis sur le
port généralisé du masque même en
extérieur alors le haut ce qui concerne
les masques d'abord eu ce que je tiens à
dire c'est que j'ai fait plusieurs
courriers au ministre de la santé au
premier ministre de l'époque et
d'ailleurs est la dg os en général aucun
courrier n'a même eu un accusé de
réception
et ça je trouve ça totalement
inadmissible de la part de l'état les
masques
on a maintenant des masques chirurgicaux
effectivement les stocks sont à
renouveler nous nos stocks
il en est pas du tout de même pour les
masques ffp2 les masques ffp2 sont
toujours denrée rare et c'est ce qui
protège réellement les masques
chirurgicaux ou les masques fait maison
sont utiles effectivement pour protéger
les autres et c'est ça qu'il faut bien
que les gens comprennent c'est que ces
masques c'est un devoir civique
c'est à dire qu'on ne met pas un masque
chirurgical pour se protéger parce que
la protection d'un masque chirurgical
comme d'un masque fait maison n'est que
de 30% environ
mais le masque en fait il n'empêche nos
postillons personnel d'aller contaminer
notre voisin et je pense
qu'effectivement dans les endroits où la
distanciation physique ne peut pas être
respecté je pense que le masque est
utile merci à vous jean philippe masson
d'avoir répondu en direct aux questions
je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
radiologue libéral à carcassonne
président de la fédération des médecins
radiologues